d'abord je le dis investir dans ce cas
la première richesse de cette entreprise
les femmes et les hommes qui travaillent
je disais ne dépassé 70 000 salariés il
y a 271 métiers et je voudrais me fixer
trois objectifs après une phase
d'objectifs partagés à long terme
d'abord je crois qu'il est absolument
indispensable je le vois en discutant
parce que je suis un usagé maintenant
qu'on sait que peut-être les commissions
parlementaires m'accorderont leur
confiance et que je viendrai PDG de la
RATP des agents mccordent en permanence
il me raconte leur vie quotidienne vie
d'un conducteur de bus qui n'est pas ça
donc on a un enjeu
de vie au travail de qualité du travail
il y a des outils pour ça il y a des
choses qui sont engagées ça sera je le
dis une de mes priorités de la même
façon les difficultés de recrutement que
nous rencontrons aujourd'hui avec
l'Impact qui est le leur sur la
continuité du service et la qualité du
service nous oblige me semble-t-il à
améliorer encore la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences RATP et l'ouverture à la
concurrence aussi donc ça sera un
deuxième chantier le troisième toujours
sur ce domaine de
l'investissement dans l'avenir et dans
les compétences
c'est ça consistera par la formation par
l'attractivité à mettre l'accent sur
tout ce qui est la spécificité de la
RATP sur l'excellence sur les métiers
d'avenir sur le numérique sur le
technologique sur l'industrie il y a des
enjeux industriels extrêmement forts
mais aussi j'y faisait référence sur la
qualité de l'accueil l'attention portée
aux clients l'insertion des publics en
difficulté dans les nombreux chantiers
que nous avons alors là il y a trois
chantiers que je suivrai très
personnellement et qui me semble être
extrêmement porteur pour l'avenir de
l'entreprise